so did you submit your screenplays for
all I want and someone I used to know to
competitions screenplay competitions no
didn't know no I I have submitted you
know previous scripts of mine to
competitions either plays or screenplays
and I haven't won anything you know I've
got I've been placed various things but
I haven't won anything and you know and
this kind of goes back to what we talked
about earlier about taste you know I do
think that the market doesn't always
know you know and and I think for this
film for all I want the intention was
always to go out there and shoot it a
great example is this when we started to
you know structure the story and when we
started to really think about how to you
know bring that idea from you know our
heads to the page to set into screen I
told Melissa that you know this script
is going to be probably at max 75 pages
and she was a little bit kind of
surprised because I think the
industry-standard
at least is probably at least 90 95 98
or whatever you know but having done my
previous you know indie short I mean
India having done my previous indie
feature where that script was you know
clocked in at I think in 98 or 102 pages
long um and it was an indie film we
never got any of the we didn't shoot on
2% of the script and so we really had to
go into post-production in Maxim really
struggling to repeat the story together
in a way that was coherent you know and
so I knew that this film would be really
kind of short shooting schedule because
of budget because of schedule and so the
intention was how do we go into
post-production in the editing room with
as much of the script as possible right
so that we can really go in there
armed with all the tools you know for
the editor you know it's it's it's a
waste of time and a waste of kind of you
know vision to have a 98 page script and
you go into a you know ten-day sheet
schedule where you can only shoot seven
pages a day the math the math is going
to basically squeeze out 15 20 pages out
of your script you know and so that's a
good example is that we didn't really
write the script with the intention of
going out there and submitting it to
contests or or going out there to try to
raise money we really this was really
the blueprint for this kind of journey
that we were going to go on it was the
road map for this trip that we're going
to take and and so you know we really
kind of nailed it down to a
quote-unquote you know short
feature-length script by industry
standard you know but the in process is
that we have a full-length feature film
that's you know over hour and a half so
so you thought if I take out 20 pages
that will save us X amount of dollars
because we won't be here I don't know
how many you figure what right now two
more days or three more two whatever how
many days right because I mean you know
I mean I mean I think you know what it
comes down to for filmmaking for indie
filmmaking is at some point it comes
down to math you know if you are
shooting 10 days and you are probably
going to be budgeted at seven eight
pages a day right then that means that
you're probably going to have a 70 80
page script and if you want to have you
know enough time for the actors to kind
of play around a little bit if you want
to give enough time for your crew to
give you a good kind of a you know set
in terms of lighting if you want to have
have a little room for making those
mistakes on set then you know if you go
into a production telling your first ad
that I need to shoot ten pages a day
that's that's just really kind of unfair
for the product
and you know what ends up happening is
that you go into post-production with
20% of your script missing you know and
you know it's really tough so if you
hadn't done someone I used to know and
I'm sorry I don't know how much time
went by between a both projects but you
probably would have been gone in with
the mindset of let's do industry
standard absolutely it's not I knew
pages yeah absolutely
you know you go in they're not you go in
there with this purely artistic you go
in there and express something and and
you know everybody saying kind of let's
do it director producer you do it and
then the first day of shooting the crew
limit cast we're getting to know each
other and then you miss you know you
miss I would say one scene even if it's
one scene and then you go into the next
day already behind and then you on the
next day we're behind and the next thing
you know at the end of the production
schedule you've missed you know a nice
chunk of of your movie so you know I I
think that without that experience
without having gone through that um I
probably would have been like man let's
go out there with a full-length script
and let's just do our best you know and
I think we probably would have had some
struggles you know in terms of narrative
in post-production sure and then there's
that whole romantic notion of like hey
I'm in LA and I'm on a set right and
this is cool and I mean I'm doing that
yeah but then time and money slip away
so were you always so disciplined was
that there was just something that was
gained from this last production or were
there other things that kind of helped
you become that on point because I'm
sure that's not fun to have to be that
guy on bled but you you essentially have
to I mean I think I think it's it's just
having an idea of what you can
accomplish and what you can't accomplish
you know
you you I mean I was I was saying to you
know some of our people in the crew
during pre-production was that at some
point the artistic kind of you know a
journey becomes a kind of a business
journey you know and you have to I mean
I literally was using words like we
really have to manage assets and
liabilities you know great um and and a
good example is you go into production
with a hundred page script and that's
your asset you know and then you look at
the budget and you look at your schedule
and then suddenly that that script
becomes a liability because you can't
shoot the extra 15 pages and then the
crew is like oh my god we're behind well
behind behind and that puts a certain
type of energy on us on the set so to
answer your question you know I think I
think the the consensus between Melissa
and I was always let's prepare this
product for success you know let's let's
try to like create AB roadmap and we
wrote the movie for a location that we
knew that we had access to you know in
the location changed several times
during pre-production and I had to go
back in there and and and basically
tinker a little bit and so that's
another thing is I think you have to go
in there with with as much as much of
information as you can
I'm seeing still again seeking balance
seeking you know one scale is tipping
more and then you're rewriting to fit
the scene and it sounds like you did an
excellent job with that yeah yeah yeah
and we had an amazing
we had an amazing you know scimitars for
ruin omalley I mean he came from New
York I mean I literally met him you know
we had phone conversations and emails
leading into the production but I
literally met him two days you know
before filming you know I picked him up
at LAX with Melissa on Thursday we
started shooting on Saturday and we did
a text scallop on the Friday
and we had dinner and talked about kind
of what we wanted to do and so we had an
amazing editor you know along the way
Derick drew an amazing sound designer
composed along the way we have so many
people who were you know getting paid
you know a far less than they deserve
and and so I certainly was seeking the
balance of trying to make sure that all
the pieces were in the right places you
know but at the same time you know comes
down to the kind of group of people that
you have to collaborate with
you